let me uh fix this we're about to take a
walk out of the truck oh yeah let's go
walk out of the truck oh talking about
thick Papa oh no so this is Brandon
chubby talks about life and death this
gets real this is going to be so
insightful this gets really
philosophical
I want you to listen very closely when
he mentions his favorite uh his favorite
composer he does say that I just take
off sprinting towards the 18 wheeler and
I'm running I thought it was water I'm
running through and I smell it's water
you get water gas because we hit the 18
wheeler and 18 wheelers have big gas
tanks there's gas like a die-hard movie
all over the ground and then I don't if
it's true or not based off action movies
in the 90s if there's like a spark that
thing goes up you know like a [ __ ]
like crazy so I'm like oh my God this is
awful so I get through that and then
when I get to the car this kid was I
don't know man probably eight and he's
in a uh child seat and he's and he's in
shock he's going I don't want to die I
don't want to die I'm like you're not
going to die buddy oh this is him
remember when he was a hero and he saved
the kid's life
Papa
I didn't die
but I can't get the door open so yeah
they had pulled out of this
[Music]
I'm so sick of cold opens
I think we're gonna look back on social
media like cell phones
10 years and be like oh I can't believe
we just let this be the wild west like
the people that committing suicide to
depression so he wants more censorship
because they're being mean to him see
that we're that's that's where we're at
right now shouldn't people have to the
the uptick and therapist like it's the
upticking therapist you know why there's
an uptick in therapist because all you
[ __ ] Gaslight your other friends to
say you're oh I'm doing so much better
since I saw Julian MC Goldstein he's
making me feel real good and then before
you know it all your podcasts are just
you talking about your therapy sessions
and [ __ ] dogs also how come all this
uptick and therapy sessions all these
people are getting like all therapists
are getting more work there's more
therapists and yet people are getting
worse you ever think maybe the
therapists are the problem
be a man hold it in here you were in the
UFC for Christ's sakes be a [ __ ] man
be stoic
media man because now what happened to
Gary Cooper
we're comparing ourselves to everybody
in the negativity like oh this is going
to YouTube comment on something you love
like there's no way someone's gonna hate
on Mozart Mozart who's what's your
favorite song that Mozart made what was
your favorite Mozart song
by the way as if he's ever been near any
classical composer any sort of music
that he's ever been around has included
a skirt and a Playboy in it yo I
listened to Mozart Beethoven and batch
nice hoodie [ __ ] but I'm more of a
Wagner guy yeah
go to the comments even a Mozart or uh
excuse me
Wagner Mozart okay now Wagner Papa
pronounce it in the proper German in
like some great song Whatever song you
like go read the comments so it's like
holy [ __ ] and who hates on this so it's
just like
there's a movie about composers feuding
with each other it's actually very well
known that they used to [ __ ] on each
other because it was on the East Coast
yeah no you're the west coast and then
they what biggie was at the same Studio
when Tupac got shot and a lot of people
say it none of doing it but the con you
know the coincidence made him get crazy
and it spiraled into a cycle of
Bloodshed I meant like Beethoven oh did
they shoot at each other too they did
drive-bys and [ __ ] no they didn't have
guns they just kind of hung out and
played music that's gay I mean I guess
and people a lot of people are you know
hurt people you know hurt that's what
they do so those people man cool man
more [ __ ] the third that's more [ __ ]
that's therapist therapist talk their
lives so they're just whatever it is
it's triggering so there's a lot of
people out there that hurt people that
really aren't hurting yeah they had an
entire island of pedophiles and the
whole island was just made up of all
these dignitaries from around the world
and they had everything they could ever
want you could just call it Puerto Rico
like what are you gonna call it that
come on now they're not going to vote to
become a state please don't
triggering is that is that free does
that freak you out for like as a father
because I don't have kids I have nephews
and I think about like I'm a grown man I
could you're a grown man who has a hat
that's like two sizes too big what is
that about is that a look now you're
wearing a bracelet made of colored beads
Jesus [ __ ] Christ are you gonna call
Benny the jet Rodriguez's game at the
end of this
I like to think I can handle it a little
differently are you also wearing PF
Flyers I hope he ends up like Benny the
jet Rodriguez yeah developing child
a short child going to their world of
social media freaks me out he's the one
that got stabbed to death right at the
end yeah pretty sure okay yeah whichever
one got stabbed at that that's the one
Rodriguez might be Puerto Rican that's
that song that's on brand awful it
freaks me out awful especially now being
born into it I wasn't born into it me
neither I mean so I was more like the
custom 89 but I at least had some taste
of that world a normal childhood yeah
exactly yeah no it's not good I mean I
fought with my wife like my son's
birthday cake or were surprising he's
coming downstairs she has her phone I'm
like what are you doing not who's this
for we're here man and like you if you
go to a concert any concert everyone has
their phone I mean nor okay the concert
I agree with but but people used to do
that in our days when there was a
barrier of entry and it was very
expensive to have like a video my dad
had a camcorder I remember
and I agree with you like you don't need
to film everything in life but like I
understand why parents film birthdays
that way they could show like you know
grandkids and and show the grandpa hey
look this is the there's a certain
acceptable level of it yeah if you're
taking a phone out to take a video real
quick or a picture if you're not one of
these people that's constantly doing it
like every [ __ ] four seconds but yeah
it's you can't come there you want to
see the that's part of like life is
going back looking at memories you
[ __ ] [ __ ] especially for you you
have severe brain damage You're Gonna
Want Some videotapes of your kids having
great moments because you're not going
to remember a lot of this sir
they're like we're living in simulations
like you choose to yeah because you're
at let me get this straight you're at
the concert where you're viewing it
through your he's doing something that
prop welcome to 2012. these are
Brendan's observations hey is your CTE
brain won our window of [ __ ] internet
explorer do you just get things now this
what what what's the next bit you're
gonna do airplane food it's like man
just live in the moment man it's like
you go out you see so many people with
their heads in their phones man it's
like they're not experiencing life man
Jesus [ __ ] right in five years he's
gonna be telling people to touch grass
yeah [ __ ] guy that we used to be
addicted to Instagram and only got off
because his wife yelled at him
staying five in five years he'll be like
imitating Ryan Long's [ __ ] Cadence
and he'll be saying like hey you gotta
get out there touch grass dude yeah it's
just gonna be like what the [ __ ] you're
just picking up things five years too
late
you're gonna film his birthday party you
shouldn't run it by me
oh me you [ __ ] idiot yeah right like
why you're at the concert you know who
are you airing and who's like oh yeah
Greg's at whatever traffic hey [ __ ] I
don't know a lot of people
who film entire concerts no no but
sometimes there's a moment where you're
like okay this is cool I'm gonna take a
quick [ __ ] 30 second I enjoy those
videos I don't know about you no but
imagine like when they come up on my
timeline and somebody's like we just saw
[ __ ] Iron Maiden and they get to like
a cool part it's like all right I'm
gonna take a quick clip the guy's not
[ __ ] doing it all night it's just or
or like when a band brings up a kid to
play the guitar that's kind of cool yeah
let's check that out yeah yeah but like
it's like put the phone away and it's
like we're gonna be here for like three
hours calm down okay calm down we're
here for three [ __ ] hours if you're
on vacation don't send me a picture of
Fiji I can Google better pictures he's
doing the crystalline thing again
what are you doing for real for real but
Brandon thank you for being here man of
course man it's pretty uh it's pretty
badass to have you sitting next to me is
it why
and I do want to ask I I've you know
I've hounded you to try to you know
invite you on this podcast and you
graciously said yes was there anything
of course you said yes you're doing it
in a studio that says thick boy on the
table yeah I'll do it but you got to
rent the space in my studio yeah yes
you're right
look at that interested you and stuff
like usually when people have a
willingness to do it maybe there's some
interest in the conversation a lot
twenty dollars from dark mofo I spent
all my money on bills today think you
sent some people to my site after the
show rumble.com the peep show yeah go go
to the people guys go to the peep show
on Rumble I mean I hope it's not bad or
whether it's experience or none of that
none of that I mean I'm open-minded to
all topics so
um obviously the title of your obviously
the tile
your show I knew it was gonna be about
that open-minded is not the word you're
looking for Brennan it's your [ __ ]
airhead
s and stuff like that which is I'm
always down to talk about uh so many
people helped me out when I was coming
up so you know I give back that's just
my thing to do
um I you know I don't know if you have a
okay what about you what about in your
world because my opinion is like I have
cope with humor I'm not a stand-up comic
by any means and I think you're not even
an adult
I've humor has been a good part of my
coping mechanism but I see stand-up
comedy is usually their [ __ ] comes from
Dark Places no would you say that or
something not everywhere not everywhere
I think so I mean I don't [ __ ] think
I mean I'm not the guy to ask about
comedy man yeah what do I know you
should ask somebody who's good at it I
don't know theophon he used to talk he
used to return my phone call I would
text him right now but I don't know bro
it's like comedy comes to me like from
Mexican food names like I think that
shit's [ __ ] hilarious oh if you
really ever like really sounded out
fajita bro it's a funny word
it's a it not everywhere I mean I think
you have to have some sort of Chip jokes
come from a painful place nah b
sometimes they come from next words
complaint yes that's a good point God
I mean actually although although it's
Nick Swardson so yes they do come from a
painful place
a very drunk and painful place
you know I've always felt like an
outcast so I think Comics a lot of them
are outcasts as far as the darkness
you're gonna have some Darkness I have
some Darkness but
um you know I think there's a
misconception where it's like oh
everyone had bad childhoods and you know
this and drug addicts and it's like no
no no no only the funny ones not you
you're you're not the the funny ones had
problems is she confusing stand-up
comedians with serial killers because
that doesn't make any sense a lot of
[ __ ] stand-up comedians came from
upper middle class Jewish homes for
being honest that's two parents that's
not a that's like oh man everything
every comedian no I Rodney Dangerfield
didn't have a bad childhood hey I love
my parents they're all jokes folks no
but like it's uh you know you imagine
him having to explain all these years
later no my dad was a great guy they
would call Joe
um no but like it's just uh everybody
thinks that no those are serial killers
he's confusing yeah they think all these
guys come up from like drug addicted
homes and they were molested and people
put cigarettes out on them and you're
like that's serial killers usually have
all that in common
only like 50 of people at gas digital
like that so that's pretty kind of
[ __ ] up that you're doing that right
yeah and Louis dad Lewis's dad got
stabbed so that's not fair no to be like
oh you came from a broken home but when
Puerto Ricans die in a stabbing that
they go to Puerto Rican Valhalla because
they died in a Puerto Rican battle be
true that's true you get stabbed
anywhere in the tri-state area you go to
Valhalla and your family gets a check
like uh like the martyrs got from
[ __ ] Palestine
they come to your house with a folded a
Puerto Rican flag and a sea and a CD
with a Puerto Rican flag on it with fat
Joe's Greatest Hits and they show up and
they go yo bro on God he died a hero's
death dog oh God and it's not even a
flag it's a seat cover
don't worry bro it fits a Civic I
already tried them out you're a good
eyebrow peace oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know the musicians too like every
musician's into heroin there's really
famous ones that had issues they're good
ones for the most part the comics like
the big Comics you guys know like Bill
Burr Segura
um Rogan dude their their work ethics
would put freaking LeBron James to shame
you know it's like those guys don't have
any [ __ ] problems now in their
childhood I'm sure you know there's
everyone has trauma you know even the
rich kid in the penthouse in Beverly
Hills has trauma to him that he's that's
his perspective so everyone has trauma
right but this idea that every comic's
dark and all it comes from you know a
very dark place yeah for some that works
but a lot of them are just normal dudes
right who are very gifted and fun
normal is boring first off I get it but
you're not gifted and funny every time
somebody and it's it's always these
low-level [ __ ] come up and coming
podcasters do your do your job do what
you got to do I get it but like
they always what bothers me is when they
in When anybody interviews him like
because Brendan like Brandon's some sort
of
person you should be asking about comedy
like he's not he's not he's an idiot do
not take this man's advice because the
only advice he could give you is be
friends with Joe Rogan
that's it
yeah actually I always have a face like
what I say is a form of expression so I
wonder if it's just literally just if it
where it comes from who is this guy uh
some idiot who the [ __ ] is dead to 59
000 Subs ain't that small yeah but I
also I think I'm a super
nated person so it's like you know on
stage
that's the one place where you're not
gonna get in trouble because it will not
inspires a ticket they agree that not
none of this is sick
ah
five takes
five takes to do a 25 minute special
you're here to laugh by any means
necessary well not ever go to a Brandon
show yeah so whether it's left right
woke whatever it is transgender gay
straight it doesn't matter you bought
the ticket and you have agreed verbally
that nothing this shouldn't offend you
these are jokes all right so
tell that to Michael Richards or how
about this how about this brand remember
when you buried Shane Gillis oh you're
about to say something yeah Barry Shane
Gillis hey that was a clip from his
[ __ ] paywall podcast that was from a
premium episode of his podcast so
everybody that was meant to hear the
ching chong [ __ ] joke there was
supposed to be people who bought the
ticket remember when his thing was I
just think it's not far just like
shingles it's not funny it wasn't funny
it's not funny yeah probably one of the
[ __ ] funniest people around right now
Jillian keeves isn't one of the funniest
SketchUp channels right now stop it but
he did that but he got he was like I
remember Isis Toyota he's done some bro
forget about changelis's stand up which
is very funny his sketches are [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] bro and it's the one
place where you know you can get away
with it because you can't get away with
it on YouTube can't get away with it on
social media you know where you can get
away with it on Rumble
we have been the spiciest we've been
since the fifth Circle things to be
honest with you and it's so nice I look
forward to this again it's so great I
have we haven't even gone that crazy no
but if you [ __ ] stop saying jokes
exactly
away with it on the news but wait wait
wait till our Christmas special episode
blood and soil tune in for that one
stand-up comedy that's the one everyone
else is celebrating Jesus's birth we're
going to be getting to the bottom of who
killed him and why we celebrate his life
[Music]
foreign
my theory is Italians but I just saw the
pictures
you know
rumbles
loving having us on this [ __ ] thing I
think they are what greed that you can't
come for this in this Lane you cannot
come first right and they try they still
try to come but it's a it's gonna be a
tough one yeah it's never gonna stop my
shoes keep sticking together for the
velcro the Dion's dude I got school I
gotta I'm not gonna lift my feet up for
the camera these are great um I'm kind
of taking it back a little bit when you
when you sorry about your grandmother
that you lost for the fight
you mean the grandmother that you went
and you don't know who she you literally
posted about funeral fit remember
funeral is grandma's funeral
on Instagram oh my God yes I can Flex on
the haters or whatever funeral fit boys
do you remember
do you remember what afterwards because
I still want to keep it on theme in
regards to like do you remember a
process of dealing with it you just kind
of you just truck on no it's struck on
yeah I think what helps me is even back
then I wasn't as busy I am now but I uh
I was fighting so I was like and I lost
that fight so I was trying to figure out
my camp and I moved to California and it
was like a new thing so it was like I
was so busy I could put that to the side
and I knew she was cool with the choice
so just like cool man it's also you know
that's what old people do yeah they die
so he's added is it more to the fact
that you had that conversation with her
that's somebody slipping to me thank you
slipping to me
we kind of glossed over the fact that
this dude has velcro shoes still
because he said the velcro's sticking
well maybe they're uh more comfy
look I wouldn't be against going back to
velcro shoots if we can make them
fashionable okay
prior thinking she was cool she didn't
feel like you had like a process to work
I think I would been like that no matter
what like I'm a guy he's just a funny
guy naturally funny guys
you know they just called that's why
they say man they always say breading
kills bro I always say that man Brandon
was here tonight he killed he did he
killed the room he killed he killed
everyone left yep they were gone
he killed the bartender's tips killed
everything
like the lightning being [ __ ] uh like
the Avalanche beating the lightning five
nothing in a sports bar yeah no
seriously watching the [ __ ] all the
people go could I get my check please
this is not working yeah the only thing
he killed was the sex drive of whoever
brought he brought to this [ __ ]
Raptor
listen my kids and my my father did this
with me it's in especially in sports but
it translates to everything in life is
like
you know if you throw an interception
you don't have to see dwelling on you're
not thinking about that it's on to the
next play man yeah but here's the
problem here's here's the problem Ryan
Leaf of Comedy all you do is throw
interceptions you don't throw anything
but interceptions you are an
interception machine
and so in life it's like I've had some
tough breaks man and I don't dwell on it
at all yeah or people come for me you
know other you know people talk [ __ ] or
whatever trying to create drama in the
podcast she failed upwards media I will
think about that for literally five
minutes and I move on wearing your head
homeboy if you only think about it for
five minutes Brian Callan wanted to come
with a bunch of legal documents
threatening to send the FBI to Bobby Lee
so no the fact that he's trying to play
cool as a cucumber while at the same
time panicking about social media go
[ __ ] yourself Brendan how about that you
want funny prick I'm so sick of this guy
it doesn't and it's fake sincerity you
want to be Rogan so bad but you can't
[ __ ] be Rogan that's the problem all
of you guys want to be Rogan but you're
not going to [ __ ] be Rogan all you'll
ever be is when they say Brandon Schaub
you know what they're gonna say oh
Rogan's friend
yeah you'll never be Rogan uh-huh you'll
always be a guy who knows Rogan
congratulations Garfunkel you're killing
it that's not true Uncle actually
contributed to the band yeah oh sorry
he's the and Simon and Garfunkel your
[ __ ] Colonel Robert Parker yeah [ __ ]
you I [ __ ] hate this guy it's it's
that that fake sincerity is what really
bothers me about him you know
yeah because you know like the meaning
of life is about not being on Instagram